[Music]
English lessons hello today's mini
English lesson is on countable and
uncountable notes so what is it
countable now quite simply things you
can catch books chairs pens pencils you
name it it's probably going to be
accountable now they exist in both
singular and plural form for example one
book two books uncountable nouns tend to
refer to things over a little bit more
abstract friendship love wealth hunger
they can also refer to things that are
too numerous or too difficult for cats
for example rice pasta water some nouns
can be both countable and uncountable
depending on the context in this example
this poor gentleman only has three hairs
one two three pairs in this example this
lady has lovely long hair but it's a bit
difficult to see exactly how many hers
she has so here hair is uncountable
she's got the long hair beautiful there
are some nouns which are countable in
French and are uncountable in English
for example information and advice I
hear a lot of people asking could I get
some more informations in English
information is always uncountable so we
don't need to pluralize it the same for
advice sometimes I hear could I have
some more advices please again this
doesn't sound right in English it's
always in the singular form advice I
hope you found this mini English lesson
useful bye
[Music]